ma slim est élu représentant du peuple
députés comme on disait encore à
l'époque mais en tant que suppléant
parce qu'il remplace bicep dont
l'élection a été invalidée pour cause de
faillite frauduleuse masculine sièges
donc à l'assemblée nationale comme
troisième sur la liste et républicaine
aux côtés de victor schoelcher et
également de pierre-marie pourri
papilles le maire de saint pierre qui
après une panne importante dans
l'abolition de l'esclavagé dans la
colonie de martinique magillem en fait
ils seront aussi là discret public n
parce que de sa vie durant d'adultes
libre à paris il n'a eu de cesse de
lutter pour l'émancipation comme on
disait
l'abolition de l'esclavagé avec ses
compatriotes de martinique mais la roue
homme de couleur libres comme bissett
mais également volny fabien ou encore
baby non et ils ont eu de cesse de
récolter des fonds pour améliorer le
sort des esclaves des colonies
françaises notamment en guadeloupe et
martinique
et c'est ainsi que il doit par son
militantisme discret mais ces antennes
efficace à paris le fait qu'il ait été
l'un des candidat suppléant sur la liste
républicaine et il s'acquittera de sa
tâche pour surveiller notamment la mise
en place du nouveau régime administratif
économique et politique dans les
colonies qui sont enfin débarrassé de l'
esclavage